the saharan desert and north africa at
large is one of the world's greatest
untapped energy resources the solar
energy that strikes the surface of this
desert has the potential to power the
entire world a single solar panel placed
here in algeria is capable of generating
three times more electricity than the
same panel placed in germany what was
once a geographic disadvantage the
scorching sun of these desolate lands
could now provide an economic boom for
these historically impoverished nations
a panel in a solar farm located here one
square meter in size would on average
generate five to seven kilowatt hours of
energy each day increase that to one
square kilometer and we are generating
five to seven gigawatt hours of energy
each day increase that to one thousand
square kilometers and we are generating
five to seven terawatt hours of energy
each day enough to satisfy nearly 100
of europe's energy needs
multiply that by 10 and we are
generating 50 to 70 terawatt hours a day
enough to power the entire world
this is an impressive and often repeated
statistic
napkin calculations that draw a drastic
new vision of the world a solar powered
utopia plans have even been drawn up to
transform the simple mathematics into a
reality but reality has a way of
interfering with futuristic pie in the
sky calculations like this
every plan to turn this dream into
reality has failed in this episode we
are going to learn why
transporting electricity out of these
remote regions is the first challenge
currently there are only two
interconnections connecting north africa
to europe
both are located between morocco and
spain
two 700 megawatt interconnections one
completed in 1998 and the second
completed in 2006
with a third connection expected to be
completed sometime before 2030 for a
total of 2100 megawatts if we wanted to
transport enough electricity to power
europe ignoring transport losses and
storage issues we would need
592 to 831
more of these 700 megawatt
interconnections these aren't just
simple cables that we lay between
countries
they are incredibly complicated and
expensive pieces of infrastructure the
third interconnection joining morocco
and spain's grids is estimated to cost
150 million dollars an enormous
investment that will see both countries
footing half the bill
592 more of these connections would cost
at an absolute minimum 8.9 billion
dollars and that number was found by
simply multiplying 150 million by 592
but these connections are the shortest
route to europe from north africa they
are going to be the cheapest to build to
build a truly interconnected grid we are
going to need even longer
interconnections connecting tunisia to
sicily algeria to sardinia and onwards
to northern italy libya to crete and
onwards to greece and turkey and to the
rest of the middle east network all the
while building enough internal
interconnections in europe to facilitate
the passing of the solar paracel
northwards while wind is traded south
this plan will take billions to complete
yet even with these issues european
leaders have drawn up plans to connect
north africa and the middle east to
europe they believe the cost can be
recovered desertec is or perhaps more
appropriately was a german-led
initiative centered around a
half-trillion dollar investment fund
that would invest in generation and
transmission infrastructure across north
africa and the middle east 55 billion
was allocated to increasing transmission
capabilities across the mediterranean
this investment would go into both high
voltage alternating current transmission
over shorter gaps like those from
morocco to spain and high voltage direct
current over longer distances
there is a critical distance where high
voltage alternating current transmission
does not make sense
if we plot transmission losses per
kilometer for ac and dc transmission it
would look something like this with dc
losing less power per kilometer
however in order to convert our regional
ac grid power to dc for these long
distance transmission cables we need
expensive transformers and converters if
we instead plot cost versus distance
counting in this infrastructure it would
look something like this and we can see
that the dc and ac lines cross each
other around the 500 to 800 kilometer
mark this is the break-even point where
dc becomes more cost effective
so lines connecting morocco directly to
spain which spans only 28 kilometers
don't make sense for high voltage dc
while longer lines connecting tunisia to
italy will likely be high voltage direct
current lights
transmission losses for high voltage
direct current is about three percent
per 1000 kilometers and germany's
capital is only 1 800 kilometers from
tunisia transmitting power with this
much investment money is perfectly
feasible the technologies exist
so let's move into the generation part
of the desertec plan
desertec was formulated with
concentrated solar power in mind which
works very differently to photovoltaic
solar panels
concentrated solar power facilities
would be spread out along the borders of
the saharan and arabian deserts
one such facility already exists in
morocco and it's the largest
concentrated solar power plant in the
world
it is massive with three separate
sections nor one two and three each
using slightly different variations of
concentrated solar power
combining to provide
510 megawatts
nor 1 and 2 are both trough-based
systems that use parabolic mirrors with
the tube located in the mirror's focal
point the tube contains a synthetic oil
which collects the heat from the 500 000
parabolic mirrors spread out over 308
000 square meters
this oil becomes extremely hot as high
as 400 degrees celsius which allows it
to boil water and heat exchanger to
drive a steam turbine which provides
electricity for the grid
the 400 degree oil is also hot enough to
melt salt in a molten salt heat storage
system the molten salt heat storage
system of nor1 can store enough heat to
keep the plant operational for three
hours while nor2 has enough energy for
seven hours however this salt solidifies
at 110 degrees and if that happens the
plant won't work in the morning so nor 1
and 2 need a fossil fuel burning system
to keep all the working fluids of the
system at minimum operating temperatures
overnight and to keep the oil system
pumping this fossil fuel burning system
can also keep the plant operational as a
reliable baseline energy source
removing the need for separate natural
gas peaker plants
nor3 does not use these parabolic
mirrors and instead uses a tower system
it's this striking circular facility to
the north it looks less like an
industrial facility and more like a new
age burning man art installation
this design allows north 3 to rid itself
of the oil plumbing and pumps of nor1
and 2 and instead it uses mirrors
arranged in concentric circles around a
central tower the mirrors are then
controlled to focus light on a single
point on the tower which directly heats
the molten salt which is the working
fluid instead of the oil based system
the solar concentration here is much
higher and in turn the temperatures
attained are much higher with the water
being heated to 550 degrees
this allows the tower-based system to
use more efficient steam turbines and
using molten salt as the working fluid
removes the need for an oil to molten
salt heat exchanger in the heat storage
system north 3 is the world's only
operating tower based concentrated solar
power system with molten salt storage
after 2019's shutdown of nevada's
crescent dunes plant the crescent dunes
plant ceased operation in 2019 after
only four years of operation nv energy
broke its purchasing contract with the
plant after it failed to meet
performance requirements being marred by
maintenance issues including an
eight-month shutdown due to a leak in
the molten salt tank even when fully
operational the plant's electricity cost
135 dollars per megawatt hour while a
nearby photovoltaic plant was managing
30 dollars per megawatt hour and here
lies the crux of the issue concentrated
solar power costs per megawatt was
extremely competitive with photovoltaics
in 2009 but in the last decade
photovoltaics have become obscenely
cheap concentrated solar power simply
cannot compete in a market like this and
the same can be seen for nor one two and
three however they are currently being
measured on a metric called levelized
cost of electricity which is an average
of the cost to generate electricity over
the entire life of the plant
but this does not factor in the cost of
storage for photovoltaics which is often
just an inherent benefit of concentrated
solar thermal power
so going forward the industry should be
using a combined cost of storage and
cost of electricity metric yet the most
recent addition to this solar farm is
nor4 a solar panel farm contributing 73
megawatts with the rise of cheap solar
panels desertec contrary to what you
might expect was doomed for failure
concentrated solar thermal power by
nature needs a lot of land
the plant has a minimum viable operating
temperature and to achieve that we need
enough mirrors to reflect that light
solar panels do not have this problem
solar panels can be fitted on top of
homes over car parks or even in farmers
fields to help shade plants that need
shade we don't need massive plots of
land to make them work and because they
are so cheap it's perfectly feasible to
build smaller solar farms in germany and
avoid those transmission losses and not
incur the massive financial risk of
investing billions into a country that
is not your own
that's particularly important because a
lot of investors are very hesitant to
put money into these often volatile
countries we need to look no further
than the 2013 attack on a bp natural gas
plant in algeria to see why this would
be considered a risky investment in many
parts of north africa
it's a vital economic resource for
algeria yet it sits isolated in the
midst of a vast desert that's a transit
route for al qaeda in north africa
no wonder it was so difficult to defend
and such a tempting target for the
militants
this is all exactly why germany is
instead investing in its own domestic
photovoltaic generation and in 2020
solar power accounted for 10 of
germany's power generation
this idea of european countries drawing
natural resources from africa to benefit
their own economy has some undeniable
problematic historic parallels
any foreign investment like this is
going to come with some guarantees of
supply for europe beyond the
difficulties of organizing cross-border
cooperation like this
that's not going to go down well when
the country hosting these plants needs
the power for their own grid to power
their economy or simply stabilize their
own grid for current needs it becomes
even more problematic when you consider
the amount of water these facilities
need for cooling for the steam turbine
and to keep the mirrors clean this
facility in morocco uses 2.5 to 3
billion liters of water every year
taking water from a dam 12 kilometers
away
morocco is already susceptible to
droughts so scaling these water demands
up just to feed europe's power needs
while taking water away from the farms
that feed moroccan citizens is even more
problematic to truly scale this power
generation some technological
improvement that reduces the consumption
of water would be needed or just paired
the facilities with desalination plants
and use the extra water if any to
irrigate local farms to boost local
economies even more
for this dream of turning the earth's
barren deserts into energy generation
centers to come true it has to be a
grassroots movement not some new age
imperialism mega project that comes with
a whole host of guarantees in exchange
for the nearly half trillion dollar
investment
north africa is one of the hardest hit
regions in the world by climate change
with desertification and water scarcity
becoming a serious issue this plan
despite its surface level good
intentions
sought to exploit these countries that
have suffered most as a result of
western industrialization we don't need
to look for proof that this was their
intention the moment the technology
developed to allow european countries to
provide their renewable power needs
within their own borders the plan
disintegrated the plan was never about
helping african nations
but the idea isn't dead in the water
these countries do have the natural
resources to benefit from solar energy
morocco is in the best position to lead
by example its proximity to spain allows
relatively short interconnections to the
european grid its government is
relatively stable compared to its north
african neighbours with a political
stability index of minus 0.33
algeria tunisia libya and egypt are all
much lower and while morocco has
abundant solar resources it also
benefits from consistent desert winds
along its coast
morocco has the potential to invest in
its own energy needs while exporting
access to europe leading by example
slowly shifting away from being a net
energy importer of fossil fuels and
becoming an energy exporter local
infrastructure to benefit local people
first an african nation using its
resources to benefit itself first and
foremost the potential for africa's
solar energy future is undeniable the
technologies to facilitate cross-border
energy trading exist
and investments are happening to
increase capacity for trade with this
third interconnector between morocco and
spain
funded equally by both sides ensuring a
level playing field
figuring out the best practice for
growing and improving our electric grids
is incredibly complicated electricity
grids are effectively the largest
machines on the planet hundreds of
generators scattered across countries
connected together by wires relays and
switches the task of managing that by
hand and making sensible decisions for a
single human is impossible and more and
more of the grid infrastructure is
turning towards a smart grid controlled
by algorithms battery firms employ
coding and math experts to develop
algorithms to allow them to buy and sell
the electricity they store to maximize
profit and coding jobs like that are
some of the best pain and highest demand
in the world today learning about
algorithms and coding like this is an
invaluable skill and whether you are a
high school student or experienced
engineer brilliant is a great place to
start learning and brushing up on your
skills
i recently started the interactive
course algorithm fundamentals and
learned a ton of useful and insightful
information
this is just one of many computer
science courses on brilliant that will
help you not only understand but enjoy
the information you are learning with
continual assessment to test your
knowledge but critically it doesn't
impede your progress when you get
something wrong instead each question
comes with a detailed explanation of the
solution because the best way to learn
is to try and sometimes learn through
failure if learning a valuable skill
sounds like something you want to do go
to brilliant.org forward slash real
engineering and finish your day a little
smarter and the first 500 of you to do
so will get 20 off the annual
subscription to view all problems in the
archives
if you are looking for something else to
watch right now we have a two-part
hour-long series about my favorite
airliner the 787 or you could watch real
science's latest video about the insane
biology of the axolotl
you